- L'espoir des amateurs
de baseball de retrouver
une équipe à Montréal
ne repose plus sur grand-chose.
- Ce chapitre est clos.
- Stephen Bronfman a confirmé
que la Ligue de baseball majeur
fermait la porte au projet
de villes soeurs,
une garde partagée de
l'équipe des Rays de Tampa Bay;
une demi-saison en Floride
et la fin à Montréal, dans
un stade encore hypothétique.
"Le plus dur, dit
le propriétaire de l'équipe,
c'était d'en informer ceux
qui ont travaillé  sur
ce projet ces dernières années."
STEPHEN BRONFMAN,
Groupe Baseball Montréal
- C'est difficile pour nous
à digéru'ils ont dit
oui tellement de fois et,
à la fin, ils ont dit non.
- La Ligue de baseball majeur
n'a pas communiqué les raisons
du refus, mais le , mais le , me
Baseball Montréal y voit
de la frilosité.
- Peut-être, en fin de journée,
le comité exécutif a dit :
quoi? Oui, c'est
pas une mauvaise idée,
mais on veut pas être
les premiers à le faire."
- Valérie Plante s'est dit
déçue, comme beaucoup de
Montréalais, écrit-elle,
tout en assurant que Montréal
est une ville de baseball,
que ce n'est que partie remise.
Quant au site du bassin Peel,
il ne faudrait pas s'empress
de le développer, selon
la Chambre de commerce.
MICHEL LEBLANC, prés. Chambre
de commerce du Mtl métropolitain
- Si un jour, on a l'opportunité
d'avoir du baseball majeur à
Montréal dans plusieurs années,
si le site s'est développé,
il ne sera plus disponible.
- Mais la construc
du stade a fait couler beaucoup
d'encre depuis plusieurs mois.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Il n'estion
que notre gouvernement
mette un sou des contribuables
là-dedans.
- Est-ce que les réticences
es à injes à injes à injes à ins
ont pu peser dans la balance?
Est-ce que ce sont plutôt
les joueurs qui n'appuyaient pas
le projet?
FFIN, analyste des
matchs de baseball à RDS
- Est-ce que des joueurs vont
vouloir se déplacer d'une ville
à une autre durant une saison,i.
- Il reste maintenant celui
de concilier le rêve de revoir
pe ici et pe ici et pe ici et pn
d'aménager ce secteur au très
grand potentiel au coeur
du centre-ville.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
anada, Mon